let me jump to the story from the New
York Times Trump's lawyers may become
Witnesses or Targets in documents
investigation and then we have this
lawyer representing Oath Keepers
arrested over January 6 from timcast.com
they're going after the legal
representation of people
but this is this is look guys the
president just gave a speech where he
said half the country are an existential
threat to our democracy Kareem
Jean-Pierre said this word extreme the
my Republicans are an extreme threat to
this country and democracy and doubled
down on this calling them semi-fascist
or fascist or whatever
and now they're arresting the legal
representation or at least targeting the
legal representation this is
unprecedented level of look
call it civil war or call it pre-civil
War but what we saw in the first Civil
War I caught the first Civil War the
kind of funny right what we saw in the
Civil War in the 1860s was Abraham
Lincoln suspending habeas corpus in a
corridor stretching from DC up to up to
Pennsylvania through Maryland and they
randomly arrested people they didn't
like in that Corridor and they arrested
around 30 or so members of the Maryland
legislature because they were
sympathetic to the self
when war is happening your rights are
gone what we're seeing now you can call
it some people have chatted saying that
was a pre-war speech that's something
you hear I said hitler-esque yeah I know
Godwin's law everything devolves Nazi
Germany or whatever but a president
coming out and giving a fiery angry
speech condemning half the country and
saying we have to fight against them is
insane but then when the federal
government goes after the lawyers of
people it's well beyond that it's one
thing to come out and be like Donald
Trump did a bad thing and we're going to
prove it and it's like I don't believe
you
but you know we still have to abide by
this process until we either vote these
people out fire them or or get some
accountability but show me the evidence
we did that with russiagate I very much
was like okay show me the evidence prove
it turns out it was a hoax it was all a
lie a manipulation to jam up Trump now
they're going after the lawyers this is
that's it when they go for the lawyers
they're basically saying there's no laws
there's no rules and there's nothing you
can do about it and people need to
understand how real this is like every
lawyer that took these cases for The
Oath Keepers for Trump everything they
actually would have known the risk
involved and they would have been having
conversations with their friends and
family people at their Law Firm saying
you know what could happen to you right
because you know everyone walking around
day to day they kind of think the
system's functioning properly people get
treated fairly but when you're in it you
see it you know that you're going to get
screwed over last time I came here on
timcast
um the guy who checked me in for my
immigration he freaked out when he
looked at the screen because I was
pulled into the back room for
questioning as usual and he started
passing me notes private immigration
what do you mean uh immigration on my
way in from Canada to come do this show
okay and the private notes he passed me
said that you've been put on a watch
list basically where you're going to be
pulled in for the rest of your life
because of some random agent in Seattle
I haven't traveled to Seattle in years
who put you on a list because you're
associated with people like Stephen Maul
and Yoni put you on a flag list right
that's the kind of stuff that they know
I get I get held up for eight hours
sometimes I'm not able to make flights
thousands of dollars missed and that's
just one of the operations the things
they do behind the scenes to make sure
you know but you do this this is a
perfect example to illustrate that and
what they're really doing is they're
toxifying anyone Associated
professionally or as a high-level
volunteer with the any right of Center
at anti-establishment movement they're
making sure that Trump can't staff a
government if he gets back in they're
making it so that we can't hire people
that's right so we we have conversations
periodically with high profile creatives
and there's always an issue I I know a
lot of um musicians professional
athletes and they'll message me and say
things like I agree with you the point
of this is to make them say dude I
really I really can't I'm sorry man I'll
lose everything look what they're doing
look what they're doing and but you know
what
some people are cowards and that's
that's the unfortunate reality and if
the issue is the people who agree with
freedom Liberty individual uh personal
responsibility and individualism if if I
if if if those of us if this faction is
dominated by cowards well then we
deserve to lose that being said I think
this shows we are winning I'm not I'm
not saying that to get down I'm saying
that if you look at Kerry Lake's Victory
you look at Liz Cheney losing the
midterms are looking like it's going to
be good and that was Joe Biden crapping
his pants in fear knowing he's about to
get impeached because the Republicans
are preparing an impeachment on several
fronts I pray you're right I I I pray
you're right you know people got to
register their make sure they're
registered people have to vote people
they have to get they have to register
right now
you can go out to your neighbors and say
register to vote and maybe they won't
we've had a lot of people message saying
I went out and talked to 42 people two
people registered good enough yeah
that's what we got my fear is that the
Roe versus Wade thing
I don't believe it yeah you know I don't
think so I don't think the roviolet
stuff is going to be see this is when
he's talking about this is a direct
quote from the speech backwards to in
America this is the the maggots are
taking us backwards to an America where
there is no right to choose no right to
privacy is it he's trashing us because
we don't think you should have a
limitless right to scramble a baby's
brain and vacuum it out like that that's
insane that's not even what happened the
Supreme Court just sent back to the
states right of course but most of the
country knows this not all of it but
most of the country knows that that's
what happened this is this is what
desperation looks like going after
lawyers if they were winning none of
this would be necessary right they have
they it's a death rattle it's it's they
become more and more extreme the more
this is panic you know people who are
calm and collected and know they're
going to win don't freak out and scratch
at the walls Tim I got a question for
you do you think they've done the
calculation what happens if the
conversation ends if we can no longer
speak to one another Obama lied to us
but he would at least try to convince us
he would try to bring us to his side
he's saying I don't want to talk to you
I want to shut you down I'm gonna stick
the FBI on you I got 87 000 new IRS
agents I got the military behind me he
kind of looked like he was in like a pit
of Hell like with that red background
what was that about well it looked more
like V for Vendetta moment will happen
yeah so but but do you think do you
think they get it that if we can't talk
it's gonna get much worse in this
country if we can't talk to one another
look
in 2019 you know I'm talking to Jack
Dorsey and he mentioned on Rogan show
sure liberal journalists only follow
liberal journalists and conservatives
follow liberal and conservative
journalists that's right it has always
been the case that one side of the
country was brainwashed in the cult
thinking they weren't brainwashed into
cult and it was everyone else that's
still true today absolutely Bill Murray
show with Rob Reiner oh man but but even
Bill refused no but I'm saying Reiner
right refused to admit that that the
hunter Biden laptop was hidden right he
refused to admit it but Bill Maher is
the one who said if a recession stops
Trump then bring on the recession now
all of a sudden he has the nerve to come
out and be like they shouldn't have hit
the laptop well I'll say this yeah
respect for doing the right thing Bill I
just wish he did the right thing in the
first place I don't believe he was
ignorant to what was going on I think he
was pandering because he was saying what
he thought liberals wanted to hear now
he realizes the wokeness has gone insane
and the safe bet is in the moderate
space the number one rule in politics
has always been it's better to be wrong
too late than right too early yeah
always for these people well uh what's
the what's the saying
um
what is it it's something like uh
telling the truth is dangerous when the
government is wrong or something like
that you know you know that quote Yeah I
wonder if by the way that Biden was
speaking in that speech was still as if
the maggies were a small minority of the
country right like they're that's what
it is I kept saying like oh we've got
all these Republicans I don't care what
your opinions are as long as you're for
democracy and protecting the Integrity
of this nation like I I wonder if he's
actually trying to Gaslight people do
they not realize we can look at the
voting numbers yeah we can see how many
people are maggies I want to point out
like
yeah they're trying to peel them away I
was I was talking about uh Mark Ruffalo
the other day he's uh you know he plays
the Hulk yeah I'm sure uh you know and
he gave an interview to variety and it
was actually one of the funniest things
I'd ever read because they asked him if
you know something like are you gonna
play the Hulk in the future and he said
maybe you know we'll do old Hulk because
there's like old Hulk but he goes you
know the way the way things are headed
and what we're facing right now in this
country there might not be a world in
which we can do these things so I hope
I'm still around to do it and so he's
kind of saying like the world may end as
we know it so I can't play the Hulk
anymore and and that was an intense
thing because I don't completely
disagree with him to be honest but the
best part was the variety interviewer
goes ah okay moving on so anyway and I'm
like dude just told you the world was
ending he he does this all the time he
he'll tweet something suggesting the
world's ending and then he'll have a
headshot of himself with a smoldering
hot look just like he's trying to seduce
people with his insane left-wing
rhetoric but well but but it was great
content for us so we're grateful people
yeah I mean look I don't disagree with
them I don't agree with him politically
yeah when he said we're headed towards
dark dark days or whatever he's implying
I think he's right but my ultimately
what I want to get to is
you know
earlier today I'm skating I'm trying to
I'm going up on the half pipe or the
quarter pipe I'm getting big air I'm
having a good time I'm skating and I'm
thinking you know like things are going
well the midterms are probably going to
be good we got the chickens you know
life is good I'm watch I'm I'm watching
uh I'm reading stories about TV shows
people are making fun of She-Hulk and
I'm like that's kind of normal like in
the new She-Hulk show she's twerking and
everyone's like cringe and then and then
and you get the orange eggs like the
orange yolk and the eggs with the with
the with the chickens well it changes
colors it's passing the chicken I guess
so cool I'm super jealous Yeah well yeah
it's it's good stuff sometimes they're
really dark and my point is it was a
good day today and then Joe Biden comes
out and he's like you're all evil the
world is ending and we're gonna destroy
you and I'm like nah I'm kind of freaked
out you know like look this is this
speech like you said
I want somebody to take his speech in
the setting and put someone else's words
into it from
a certain period of our history the
1930s and see how that matched up it
would be you know how they do these
memes yeah you've seen some of these
shows that was that look I know you're
familiar with uh it's Godwin's law right
is that what it is you're familiar that
all internet arguments ultimately
devolve to the point of calling someone
a Nazi or something but to have a
president come out right right and say
half the country man are a threat to our
democracy it's just kind of like yeah
it's really crazy I think Robert made a
good point earlier when he said there
that he's trying to tear these people
away have you ever heard of Hungarian
salami tactics that the Communists used
where they would kind of find little
groups or fringes or protest activism
and then they'd publicly blast them and
make them so unacceptable to be
associated with that they'd cut them off
and then they'd slowly just do it to one
more group one more group one more group
until all of their opposition was
divided and right now they're trying so
hard to divide the mega Republicans with
the regular Republicans
and I mean and they keep doing they
applaud these other people that are
peeling away and those people bring
people with them and now Mom and Pop
that really don't know and are scared
about the economy and what's happening
to the world are sitting there going
you know what do I do older older people
Unfortunately they get their news from
the from the TV and the TV is lying to
them right so you know making sure that
we can spread the word among well I mean
it's it's it's it's there's also the
problem with the younger people getting
their news from just Cults you know what
I mean in school yeah yeah yeah so it's
ultimately just about finding where
people get their information and helping
expose them this is the thing that
Ronald Reagan said the most important
thing and I wrote it on Breitbart the
weak Trump won
I said for his administration Ronald
Reagan the last speech he gave to the
American people and the last part of
that speech is farewell speech was we
need to have an informed American
patriotism the most important thing he
says we used to sit around the TV show
and we would have shows giving American
values we would sit around discussing
things with American values he says and
I fear and he saw the flag getting this
he says I fear that unless we have a new
American patriotism where we're teaching
our children Civics and the history of
America
we're going to lose our nation thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there